as promised we looked at Exponential's
in the first half of a lesson now we're
going to go into logarithms thankfully a
lot of the the sort of knowledge and
skill that we picked up and developed
and practiced earlier today is really
just gonna sort of come along for the
ride Exponential's and logs are just two
sides of the same coin so let's just
remember what are the four features that
were always looking for first one we're
looking for the overall shape the
curvature of that graph actually then we
move that down a little bit so that you
can see it more clearly we want to make
sure that unlike the exponential curve
which gets steeper and steeper as you go
the logarithmic curve gets shallower and
shallower as you go so it models things
that as they increase in size get
smaller and smaller in terms of their
rate of change we've got the shape there
and we've also got the intercept and
even though I've only marked in one as
you can see in from the exponential
examples and also the examples we're
going to look at shortly now you will
sometimes if the curve is positioned
correctly you will get more than one
intercept and if you get more than one
intercept that means you don't need for
the point for scale it provides enough
information for you I've got this
asymptote over here on the left hand
side I'm just like and I'm a bit cheeky
I haven't written down the equation of
my asymptotes here we're used to having
a horizontal asymptote of y equals zero
for an exponential curve but in this
case we're going to get a vertical
asymptote of x equals zero that's where
it defaults to unless of course we do
some kind of transformation that moves
it to a different position as you'll see
shortly and then lastly if you've only
got the one intercept then you will need
a point for scale somewhere on the curve
all right so we're good to go
let's have a look at a couple of
examples and working through together so
for starters what are we looking at here
well again I'm going to rearrange all of
my equation to make it clear what's
happening I really think that two
belongs on the left-hand side it's Y
divided by two equals log base a of X
minus one so hopefully that makes clear
to you that division by two is a stretch
vertically so this thing would be taller
than the normal log curve whoopsie-daisy
and then you've also got this minus one
just in here and that's going to make a
horizontal shift in this
case is going to go one unit to the
right okay so let's try and put all that
together and also get some information
on you intercepts asymptotes all the
rest okay so I should have mentioned as
well the overall shape if you have a
think about this it's nothing there's no
reflection happening right the there's
no - attached to the X there's no -
attached to the Y so therefore it's
going to be roughly the same looking log
curve that we just had a look at before
with no other big changes there's just
the dilation and the translation that we
were talking about okay all right so
let's have a think about some of the
information that's gonna go onto here if
I find my intercepts I'm gonna do that
by letting X equal
whoopsie-daisy X equal 0 okay so I get y
equals to log base a of 0 take away 1
now hopefully this sends some alarm
bells to you right because you might
think to yourself hold on I'm thinking
of some number you raise e to the power
of this number and what you get is
negative 1 there is no number that if
you raise e to that power you'll get
negative 1 you can get very small
numbers but you can never get negative
numbers if you have a positive base in a
power of you know big numbers it just
gets really really big e to the power of
small numbers it gets tiny you know this
is going to get really close to zero
point zero zero zero zero one whatever
it is you can go ahead and put in your
calculator actually I take it back I
think that number would be too small for
your calculator to handle it will get
very small it's my point but it will not
go negative okay so this is this is
undefined there's no there's no
y-intercept on this okay
now that should not surprise us because
if you have a look up a top here and our
general shape this is what we're
generally expecting there already is not
a y-intercept on this and then if you
have a look at our horizontal
translation here it's going one unit to
the right so it's going that way so it's
going further away from the y-axis so
that's why you're not going to get a
y-intercept I do need to get next
intercept though so I'm going to that y
equals zero that means if I've
substituted in 0 equals to log base a of
X minus 1 close my back
to keep fitting to do that what do we
got here I can divide both sides by two
that doesn't make a difference so log
base a of X minus one equals zero and
now this point here I want to reframe
this not as a log equation but as an
exponential equation that'll make it
much easier for me to change the subject
to X so if you have a think about this
this is going to be e the base of the
first equation becomes the base of the
second equation so the power of 0 equals
X minus 1 so you can see here the 0 and
the X minus 1 of kind of swapped places
if you like on left on the right hand
side e to the power of 0 like everything
else so the power 0 is 1 X minus 1 still
on the right hand side so now if I add 1
to both sides you see I get an x value
of 2 which again confirm some of the
intuition hopefully you had before
because if you look back at our normal
log graph a normal log graph will have
an x intercept of 1 well I have
translated one unit to the right so
instead of having an x intercept of 1
now I have an x intercept of 2 I need an
asymptote and normally it's an x equals
0 but you sick of me saying this yet
it's moved over one unit to the right so
therefore instead of x equals 0
it'll be x equals 1 still a vertical
line and then lastly noticing that I
only have a single intercept I also will
need a point for scale so if I've got a
point for scale of say well I've got a I
can't put in x equals 0 you can see here
if I've moved this over to the right
have a look at this guy over here again
right I've moved over to the right I
don't want values to the left here
because they'll be undefined I need to
go somewhere to the right so having a
think about this I know I've got an x
intercept at 2
well let's just go one unit further over
to the right so let's try x equals 3
when x equals 3 what am I going to get
well Y is going to be equal to log
website it's 2 is it two other front
there is it 2 log base a of 3 minus 1 3
minus 1 there we go so
- I'm gonna write the natural log
because I am lazy I'm gonna write it as
short as possible I'm three minus one is
two so that's my y-value you might not
know what to log 2 is neither do I so
I'm gonna chuck it into my calculator
calculators telling me one point you
probably can't read that but it's one
point three eight six etc so I'll just
jot that down just for my own benefit
because it'll be easier to graph if I
know roughly where it is and now I've
got all of my information this is it
this is the whole lot I'm now gonna put
this on to a set of axes so I can come
to the next equation in a second I'm
gonna draw myself a big vertical axis
like so I'm going to go all the way off
to the right like that
okay now let's start to piece together
all the pieces information that I had
from before right so I have an asymptote
of x equals one so if I go ahead and put
a vertical line through like so and I
should also label it x equals one I've
also got a an x intercept of x equals 2
so noticing that this is where one is
two must be two further along so that's
gonna be Martinez two and then I'm going
to go ahead and draw my log go through
here same basic shapes I'm gonna do my
best like so just check to see that I've
gotten the right if I didn't rub out a
little bit and fix it up but I think
that the shape is okay and approaches
the asymptote like I wanted to and it
gets shallower and shallower forever
like I wanted to intercepts fine
asymptotes fine I've got to put on my
point for scale so if this is 1 and this
is 2 then 3 must be about there so let's
go ahead and put that in whoops not in a
highlighter that's not very helpful
three will be there dot dot goes up to
here and I mark in the set of
coordinates and then I labeled them
appropriately so this is 3 comma 2 log 2
and I'm finished I suppose I should put
the equation there as well that would be
a neat thing to do X minus 1 finished
okay